现在让我们再看看改进这个合约的另一个方法
有时可以直接将 ETH 或原生通证发送给智能合约
而不执行某一个具体的函数来发送通证
例如,在这里的 JavaScript EVM 上
我可以在不调用 fund 函数的情况下，向合约发送资金
然而,如果我这样做的话
这时会对我们的 fund 函数产生什么作用吗？
不,它不会被触发, 我们将无法跟踪那个 funder
我们不会在这个合约中更新那个人的信息
因此,如果以后我们想给予奖励或什么
那就不妙了,因为人们在我们不知道的情况下给合约发送资金
我们就不能给他们任何凭证或其他东西
此外
也许他们意外地调用了错误的函数
他们又可能没有使用 MetaMask，或者其他工具来告诉他们
嘿,这个交易很可能会失败
那么,在这种情况下我们能做什么呢？
如果有人在没有调用 fund 函数的情况下
给这个合约发送 ETH 以太币, 会发生什么呢？
现在,如果我们要给 FundMe 合约发送 ETH
它会直接转到合约,对吧？
这个合约不会记录这些人的情况
但是实际上有一种方法,当人们给这个合约转钱
或者人们调用一个不存在的函数
我们仍然可以触发合约的某些代码
而现在在 Solidity 中有两个特殊的函数
一个叫做 receive
一个叫做 fallback
在 Solidity 中,实际上有很多特殊的函数
其中有两个特殊的函数是 receive 特殊函数和 fallback 特殊函数
一个合约最多可以有一个使用 receive 函数
使用 receive() external payable
不需要使用 function 关键字
这个函数不能有参数不能返回任何东西
必须是 external 以及 payable 函数
这是什么意思呢？或者说看起来像什么？
好吧,让我们单独创建一个的合约来试一试
所以,在这里,我们要创建一个新的文件
叫做 FallbackExample.sol
在这里,我们要添加我们的基本部分
SPX 许可证标识符, 添加 // SPDX-License-Identifier: MIT
和 Solidity 版本 0.8.7
写合约 FallbackExample
就像这样
请随意暂停视频,动手敲代码赶上我
一旦创建好了我们的 fallback 合约
让我们创建一个变量来测试这个函数
我们将创建一个 uint256 public result 变量
让我们创建这个 receive 函数
所以我们会说 receive,它将是一个external payable的函数
我们不需要为 receive 添加 function 关键字
因为 Solidity 知道,receive 就是一个特殊的函数
只要我们发送 ETH 或向这个合约发送交易
只要没有与该交易相关的数据, 这个 receive 函数就会被触发
我们现在可以在这里做的是,我们可以说 result = 1;
所以,让我们继续在 JavaScript 虚拟机上测试这个
我们编译这个,所以我们要继续编译这个
我们将在 Java 虚拟机上部署它,
我们将部署我们的 FallbackExample
我们将看到 result 被初始值是什么
因为我们没有为 result 设置任何东西
result 当然是被初始化为 0
但如果我们向这个合约发送一些 ETH 呢？
好吧,receive 将继续进行并在这里被触发
我们实际上可以直接向这个合约发送一些数据
通过与这里的 Low level interaction
你暂时不需要关心 calldata 的含义
只需要知道这个区域是一种发送和处理不同函数的方式
而且我们可以在这个交易中添加参数,通过这里去调整上面的变量
如果我们保持 calldata 留空
就像是在 metamask 中，点击 send，然后直接选合约地址一样
同样,我们不能使用 MetaMask,因为这是一个虚拟机环境
而不是我们正在使用的网络之一
因此,如果我这样做
例如，我把这个值改为 1 Wei,并保持剩下的空值
然后点击这个交易按钮
同样,这将与点击这个发送按钮一样,但只发送 1 Wei
你认为会发生什么？
好吧,让我们来试试
我们可以在日志区看到,我们确实发送了一个交易
如果你看一下这里的描述
你甚至可以看到它说发送自 0xxx 地址
到了我们的 FallbackExample.(receive)
看起来它调用了我们的 receive 函数
这应该把我们的 result 更新为 1
因此,如果我们现在点击 result
我们确实可以看到 result 已经被更新为 1 的值
好吧,让我们继续下去,删除这个
让我们再次部署这个合约, 这一次,让我们把这个值设为 0
这次会不会被触发
所以让我们滑下来,点击交易
让我们把 calldata 留空,
我们把值留为 0
这相当于我们向该合约发送 0 个 ETH
点击交易
看起来已经通过了
你认为 result 会是 1 还是 0？
你认为是 1？你是正确的
当你向合约发送交易的时候,如果没有指定某个函数
receive 函数就会被触发（当 calldata 没有值时）
在任何其他合约如 FundMe 中
例如,当我们调用这些函数之一时
我们实际上只是用某些数据来填充这个 calldata
这些数据指向这里的这些函数之一
如果我们发送一个交易并向其添加数据
我们实际上可以调用这些函数中的一个
现在让我们再试一下,让我们再次删除合约,我们将重新部署
打开这个,result 目前是 0
receive,就像我说的,只有当 calldata 是空白时才会被触发
现在,如果我对这个交易有一些 calldata
你认为这次 receive 会被触发吗？
如果我们点击 transact, Remix 会弹出一个窗口
说 'Fallback' function is not defined
这是因为每当数据与交易一起被发送时
Solidity 会说,哦,好吧,既然你在发送数据
那你不是在寻找 receive,你是在寻找某个函数
所以让我为你寻找那个函数
嗯,我没有看到任何符合 0x00 的函数
所以我要去找你的 fallback 函数
这里，Remix 很聪明,知道我们没有 fallback 函数
Solidity 中的第二个特殊函数被称为 fallback 函数
它与 receive 函数非常相似
不同的是,即使数据与交易一起被发送,它也会被触发
因此,我们的 fallback 函数将看起来像这样
fallback() external payable{}, result = 2
fallback 是另一个不需要加 function 关键字的函数
因为 Solidity 知道这个规则
实际上,你已经熟悉了另外一个特殊的函数
我们回到我们的 FundMe 合约
例如,构造函数,是另一种不需要 function 关键字的特殊函数
Solidity 知道,当部署这个合约时,这个构造函数会被立即调用
所以现在我们有了我们的 fallback 函数
让我们继续并编译这个
删除我们的旧合约, 然后部署这个新的合约
就像这里,我们点击 result,
我们确实做到了,看,它被设置为 0
现在,如果我添加这个 0x00
然后我发送这个,然后我点击 Transact
这相当于调用一个合约中没有的函数
所以我们的合约会说："我不知道你想告诉我什么,
我要把你转到 fallback"
现在,如果我们点击 result,我们看到它已经被更新为 2
如果我们把这个拿开,Solidity 会说,嗯,
看起来你想发送一些以太坊
或者在没有指出要做什么的情况下，调用这个合约
好吧,我有一个 receive 函数
所以我接下来把你转到那个地方
因此,如果我们调用 transact,我们点击 result,我们看到它更新为 1
添加一些数据,点击 transact
我们看到它更新为2
不填数据，就会更新为 1
solidity-by-example.org 有一个奇妙的小图例
我们可以用来分析 receive 还是 fallback 会被触发
如果它是空的, 并且有一个 receive 函数,它将调用 receive 函数
如果有数据,并且没有 receive 函数,它就会去调用 fallback 函数
如果没有 fallback 函数,它可能就会抛出 error
因此,这里有很多非常棒的信息
我们如何将其应用于我们的 FundMe 合约,
或者我们现在可以在 FundMe 中做的就是
就是添加这些 fallback 和 receive 函数
以防有人向我们的合约发送资金，却没有正确使用 fund 函数
所以我们可以做的是让我们添加一个 receive 函数
因此,如果有人不小心把钱发给了合约
我们仍然可以处理这个交易
会使用 receive() external payable
而我们只需让 receive 函数调用 fund 函数
我们将在 fallback 函数中做同样的事情
将使用 fallback() external payable,让它自动调用 fund 函数
现在,如果有人不小心给我们转钱而不调用我们的 fund 函数
它仍然会自动将他们转到 fund 函数
这同时意味着
如果有人没有给我们发送足够的资金
该交易仍将被 revert
我们现在切换到 Rinkeby
在一个真实的测试网上测试它
我在metamask上使用的是 Rinkeby
让我们切换到 Injected Web3,然后向下滚动,
我们将选择我们的 FundMe 合约,继续并部署
MetaMask 会弹出来，我将继续并确认交易
我们现在看到我们的 FundMe 合约,我们可以看到所有者,
我们可以看到我是所有者,
我们可以看到 MINIMUM_USD
当然,我们可以看到这是一个空白合约,这里没有任何资金
如果我们复制这个地址, 然后进入 rinkeby Etherscan
粘贴这个地址,我们可以看到这里没有以太币
而与此相关的唯一交易是创建合约
我们之前看到,当点击 fund 函数时
合约被更新为新的余额
并且那个出资人被添加到我们的数组中
让我们看看现在会发生什么
如果我们不调用 fund 函数而直接向这个合约发送资金
如果我们做得对的话，receive 函数应该会获取到到这个交易
并将交易转到 fund 函数上
所以让我们复制这个地址，打开 MetaMask
我们点击send，把这个地址粘贴到这里,
同样是加上 0.02 的 ETH
因为这应该超过了 usd 的最低数额限制
点击下一步
我将继续并确认这一点,稍微延迟后,如果我们这样做是对的
我们应该看到交易调用了 fund 函数
现在我们的交易已经通过了
在等待 Etherscan 可以更新后
我们确实看到余额已经更新为 0.02,当然, 这是讲得通的
我们在交易列表中看到,我们看到这实际上是以转账的方式进行的
而不是我们调用 fund 函数
让我们在 Remix 中看看我们的 funders 是否被更新
看起来它确实更新了
在下标为 0 的位置上，是有地址的
如果把地址放到 AddressToAmountFunded
我们就可以看到我们到底有多少资金
这意味着,由于在这里添加了 receive 函数
我们就自动调用了这里的 fund 函数
因此,了不起的工作,我们能够添加一个 receive 函数
以帮助那些不小心调用了错误的函数或不小心给这个合约发送钱
而不是正确地调用 fund 函数
现在,如果他们直接调用 fund 函数
这会帮助他少花一点 Gas
至少这一次,他们会得到凭证
合约会把它添加到我们的 funder 数组当中
因为他们已经给我们的 FundMe 合约转过钱了
Yeah.